good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight last night we told you
that the bid administration is funding a
number of secretive bio labs in ukraine
labs that are conducting experiments on
highly dangerous pathogens now that's
not a story as we told you we wanted to
do in fact we didn't think it could be
true it's so over the top and bizarre
and in any case the administration had
repeatedly and very aggressively denied
that they were doing anything like this
and then they attacked anyone who asked
questions about it as a tool of russia
we foolishly assume that in this one
instance they might be telling the truth
and then out of nowhere the biden
official in charge of ukraine confirmed
the story toria newland the under
secretary of state casually mentioned in
a senate hearing on tuesday that
actually yes the bite administration
does fund a series of bio labs in
ukraine and whatever is in these labs is
so dangerous that she is deeply
concerned these materials will fall into
the hands of the russian military
now that struck us as a shocking
development once again not for the first
time what had seemed like a nutty
conspiracy theory turned out to be true
tori newlin's testimony raised at least
two immediate questions what exactly are
these labs doing with our money and in
our name
and why didn't the biden administration
secure the contents of these labs before
the russians invaded
so far we haven't received any answer at
all to the second question we think
we're the only ones who've even asked it
whoever decided to leave deadly
biological materials sitting in ukraine
as russian troops masked on the border
has not yet been identified we hope that
person will be identified we'll keep
asking
as for the first question what exactly
is going on in these labs we've gotten
several answers all of them insulting
initially the administration claimed the
labs were designed to help the
ukrainians fight tuberculosis as well as
various livestock diseases that's what
officials told members of congress
it didn't seem plausible and in fact
it's not plausible
and then after our show last night the
pentagon released what it non-ironically
called a fact sheet designed to make the
bio lab story seem small and ridiculous
virtually every news organization in
america with almost no exceptions
repeated the administration's claim
verbatim with no verification of any
kind
foreign policy magazine ran this version
of it which was identical to many other
versions you saw if you followed the
news today quote fact check
dod has worked with ukraine to eliminate
in all caps bio weapons left behind by
the soviet union since 2005 said a
senior u.s defense intelligence official
but these are not again in all caps
weapons labs as russians falsely claim
the official said
the washington post assured us of the
same thing so did countless other
so-called news organizations
okay so no big deal this is not actually
a story the pentagon's been doing it
since 2005 working with ukrainians to
quote eliminate biological weapons left
behind by the soviets that makes sense
but wait
2005 was 17 years ago
how long does it take to eliminate
soviet bio weapons 17 years seems like a
long time
if you had 17 years and ample funding
from congress you could probably remove
and catalog every grain of sand on
waikiki beach
and yet somehow over that same period 17
years the pentagon has not finished
removing test tubes from soviet era
freezers
how does that work exactly how heavy are
these bio weapons do we lack the
transportation capacity to get them out
of ukraine and bury them in the desert
in nevada
when was the pentagon planning to finish
this important job in 20 years in 50
years
those all seem like very obvious
questions
but not a single reporter asked any of
those questions
meanwhile over at cnn perhaps aware that
the first explanation didn't make sense
when she thought about it offered a new
alibi
according to cnn's website the labs in
ukraine exist to quote secure
old soviet weapons okay secure not
eliminate
which raises the question what does it
mean to secure a bio weapon and again
why has it taken 17 years to do it and
by the way if these are really just old
soviet weapons
why is tori and nuland so worried
they'll wind up in the hands of old
soviets who presumably already have
these very same weapons
probably don't need more
it's absurd when you think about it
so don't think about it and that was the
point of today's coverage of the
bi-administration secret reclaiming
ukrainian bio labs stop thinking about
it
start accepting what they tell you at
face value otherwise
you are an agent of russia
here's cnn
the forboding music
biohazard warnings
this russian state media footage from
2015 claims to show america running
facilities in ukraine and georgia that
caused deadly outbreaks of disease and
killed local livestock
this story is false but that has not
stopped it continuing to circulate
evolving from biological hazards to
biological weapons and becoming a key
part of russia's disinformation campaign
justifying the invasion of ukraine
the claims were debunked several years
ago when in 2020 the united states
issued a statement to quote set the
record straight explaining the
facilities are in fact for vaccine
development and to report outbreaks
caused by dangerous pathogens before
they pose security or stability threats
these claims were debunked several years
ago these facilities works on vaccines
and reporting outbreaks
and then they play russian propaganda
the point is anyone who asks questions
about this is repeating russian
propaganda got it and the truth is we're
not interested in what russian
propagandists say about these ukrainian
bio labs we're not interested in what
the propagandists at cnn say about these
bio labs we're americans
so we would like in fact we think we
have a right to demand the bide
administration to answer simple
questions straightforward questions
these are obviously questions important
enough to make tory newland very nervous
but why
we don't know they won't answer so
instead we did some digging of ourselves
to see what we could find and here's we
came up with
the day after russia invaded ukraine
robert pope the man who heads the
cooperative threat reduction program at
dod sat for an interview with the
website bulletin of the atomic
scientists
pope is the man in charge of securing or
eliminating soviet-era bio-weapons so he
knows a lot about the subject maybe more
than anyone else
but it turns out that not all of these
soviet weapons are being destroyed or
even secured and pope acknowledged that
in the interview which apparently cnn
didn't see according to his interview
pope said the lab's quote may hold
pathogen strains left over from the
soviet bioweapons program preserved in
freezers for research purposes
pope said that quote scientists being
scientists it wouldn't surprise me if
some of these strain collections in some
of these laboratories still have
pathogen strains that go all the way
back to the origins of that program end
quote
in other words because as pope put it
scientists or scientists they don't want
to destroy all the bio weapons instead
they're using them to conduct new
bioweapons research
that's what he said
and not just on strains left over from
the soviet union
the second lie
in fact the us embassy in kiev has
acknowledged joint american and
ukrainian research on other passage
pathogens such as hemorrhagic fever
virus
apparently there's a lot of this going
on in ukraine funded by the united
states did you know that why ukraine we
don't know we can only guess
we do know that in 2010 the us
government helped fund construction of a
brand new level 3 bio lab in odessa
ukraine
the purpose of that lab was not to
eliminate or secure aging soviet weapons
no
that lab was designed for research on
new and quote especially dangerous
pathogens in ukraine
the poorest country in europe again not
a hotbed of biomedical research why
ukraine
we don't know someone should find out
we do know that the pentagon talking
points you saw reported as fact on
television today and last night were an
utter lie
did the reporters who repeated those
talking points verbatim know they were a
lie maybe they did
on the other hand how would they know
they didn't bother to do any reporting
whatsoever they got a text from somebody
administration flack and they just read
it on the air like it was true
you shouldn't be surprised because
that's what they do
and it's possible they're afraid not to
do that they know if they stray from the
script the white house is written for
them they'll be denounced from the
briefing room as tools of putin
here's biden's publicist doing that very
same thing today
the main issue that prompted my twitter
thread yesterday was that
russia has a history also of inventing
outright lies like this which is the
suggestion that the united states has a
chemical and biological weapons program
or ukraine does that they're operating
russia is the one is the country that
has a chemical and biological weapons
program so uh
the objective uh was to make clear the
inaccuracy of the information the
misinformation they're trying to put out
and make clear to the world that they
not only have the capacity they have a
history of using chemical and biological
weapons and that in this moment we
should have our eyes open
yeah but no one denies that that's the
thing no one denies that russia has a
chem bio program that's bad
no one denies that russia lies of course
and has for a long time that russian
propaganda is absolutely real of course
that's not for debate that's all true
the question is why is the united states
funding these bio labs that are not
doing anything close to what the
pentagon claims they are doing
why is the white house press secretary
from the podium
contradicting what the director of the
pentagon's bioweapons control program
has already admitted is true
why is she doing that and how should we
feel about all of this insulted but also
very concerned there is absolutely a
story here a story that matters clearly
that's why they're lying about it hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else